welcome to another doctor Sadler's
honest reviews in this series I look at
usually fairly new books that have to do
with applying philosophy to life
self-help leadership all of those things
that have to do with practical
rationality and advice about how we
ought to live today I am reviewing how
to be a friend and if that sounds
intriguing
it's it's actually titled in different
ways because this is really a new
edition of an old book by Cicero Marcus
Tullius Cicero which is generally called
the on friendship or sometimes called
the Laelius because of the main
character in Latin it's a day I'm a kid
see up and Princeton University Press
has been putting out these editions of
new translations this one is by philip
freeman so you can see here they're
they're very nicely made we'll talk
about all the good things about it in
just a moment and so this is a
essentially an older book that has been
republished and retranslated with a new
introduction by a ancient scholar so
that's what you've got here I can
actually unqualifiedly recommend the
book other than you know you should
consider whether you want to shell out
the 1695 for it but it is quite good and
it's an excellent translation it's
definitely a book that you want to read
Cicero's on friendship so you know we'll
talk about the the ins and outs of it
now
a little bit more in detail and that
will help you decide whether you want to
get this particular edition or whether
you want to go with another one
the first things that we look at are the
style the structure and a summary of the
work so style in this case is going to
refer not just to the style in English
but but also to Cicero himself Cicero is
a tough person to read and to translate
in the Latin I can tell you from
experience and this is this is a great
translation this is you know very
accessible and readable some of the
older translations can be you know a
little bit more tricky at times and it's
got a nice introduction here that's also
quite readable the introduction is
pretty short just a matter of less than
10 pages but it's it's quite good and
the structure of the work is pretty
straightforward there's there's the
introduction and that's that's really
the only other main thing other than the
further reading and the notes in the
back the rest of it is all text and
Cicero's workday AMA Kit SIA is a
dialogue or less I mean some dialogues
are very dialogical other dialogues are
more of the sort where you have a main
speaker and other people are breaking in
every once in a while there's sort of a
dramatic setting to it and that's the
kind of dialogue that that this is the
kind of dialogue that Cicero typically
writes but it is if not intensely
dialogical it's certainly dialectical
meaning that they're they're working
through a number of different important
topics and considering common and elite
points of views on those topics some of
which are to be endorsed as correct and
he'll give arguments why some of which
are going to be rejected as mistaken and
he'll not only give arguments why they
should be rejected but also delve a
little bit into the mindsets of the
who are endorsing or advocating the the
wrongheaded positions and the entire
dialogue does Center on friendship I
make it Xia something that was
incredibly important for the ancient
Greeks and an equally important for the
ancient Romans who are also drawing upon
Greek wisdom and and you know Roman
izing it or Latin izing it if you like
and Cicero played a major role in that
so the entire work centers around that
and it keeps coming back to key ideas
you know another thing that's important
to know about the style is that there
are you know quite a few references to
ancient examples meaning people who
existed in in reality you know for
example Scipio who gets mentioned in
this as a great person and a great
friend as well then there's also some
legendary people and and so you know a
lot of that is is coming from ancient
Greece and Rome and so you might not be
all that conversant with it but you know
fortunately it's you know pretty
extensively footnoted so they'll help
you out with that they can give you
enough information if you want to know
more you can figure out where to go the
other thing to say about the structure
is in this series much like the Loeb
editions there is English on one side
and the you know the other language in
this case Latin on the other side we
call this facing pages and so if you
want to be able to see what Cicero
himself actually said you can go from
the translation to the Latin which is
very nice if you know the Latin if you
don't it's not quite so helpful and
we'll talk about that a little bit later
but you know it's it's kind of nice it's
like the Loeb editions with the
exception that there is no scholarly or
critical apparatus here that where the
way there is in the the you know Harvard
Loeb editions but then you know that's
quite alright because you know you don't
need that most of the time
the summary of it so you know what
you've got here is like I said a
dialogue and it's focused on the the
topic of friendship and it's going to
consider you know the nature of the
phenomenon of friendship and why it's
important and who are good friends and
all sorts of other related topics and
they're gonna move from point to point
to point in a fairly systematic way
although there there are a few places
where Cicero himself has this character
lolly as' say oh I made a digression
here let's come back to the main point
so that's that's that's what's going on
in this and the summary you know quite
simply could be could be put friendship
is really important here's how to
properly understand it this might be
helpful for you in dealing with the
vicissitudes of friendship and other
relationships and things that we think
our friendships and actually aren't as
you live out your life in the 21st
century with using advice coming from
somebody from you know essentially two
millennia ago so that's the style the
structure and the summary of this work
in his introduction Philip Freeman
actually provides a listing of some of
what he takes to be the best bits of
timeless advice on friendship which he
says how to be a friend is filled with
and that's that's the bulk of the
introduction so I'm just gonna like hit
on some of these key points and maybe
add a few things in here and that's
that's really a decent summary of the
work so number one point there are
different kinds of friendships that's
kind of a common place in literature on
friendship the you know how to be a
friend err on friendship day a Makita is
pretty dependent on Aristotle's analysis
in the Nick and McCain and your Demian
ethics which had become kind of a
commonplace by the time of Cicero many
other authors had had picked that up so
of course that's a natural launching
point how to distinguish between
different kinds of relationships that we
call friendship that's a really
important thing to be able to do because
some friendships are friendship in the
in the truest sense and others are you
might say further away from the model a
second point only good people can be
true friends this doesn't mean that that
you can't be friendly with anybody who's
not a good person or if you're not a
good person but it does mean that if you
want to enjoy the the most lasting the
deepest the the closest to the the core
kind of friendship you actually do have
to be a good person and you know it's
interesting Cicero I'll mention when
he's talking about goodness he uses the
term virtue and he says that we don't
want to set the bar for virtue so high
that almost nobody can meet it so we
want to think about the kind of virtue
that that people that we've actually
experienced have have been able to show
us and that we might ourselves develop
towards so good is is you know an
important term here but we have to
contextualize it number three we should
choose our
friends with care this is a point that's
made at a number of different places in
the work why should we choose our
friends with care because we spend time
with them were influenced by them and
they can put us into situations that we
might not welcome if they're the wrong
sorts of people
number four friends make you a better
person okay again understanding this to
be good friends not bad friends who
exercise a bad influence on you but good
friends will in fact bring out as we say
the best in you and and try to hold you
accountable for your own actions and
choices and character here's another
nice one make new friends but keep the
old Cicero has a whole discussion in
here about why it's important to retain
old friendships and not you know sort of
take them for granted while you jump to
a new perhaps more exciting friendship
why you need to actually try to hold on
to all of your friendships but be open
to you know new relationships as well
the sixth one friends are honest with
each other friends will as I mentioned
hold you accountable they'll tell you
what you need to hear rather than just
what you want to hear so that that's
kind of important as well you know many
things that we we would call friendships
aren't truly friendships because they
don't behave in a friendly way number
seven the word of friendship is
friendship itself friendship is you
might say something intrinsically
valuable and this is something that you
know we we sometimes lose sight of in
the present but was was acknowledged by
the ancients and they they thought that
really solid genuine friendships were
kind of hard to come by but incredibly
desirable and you know many people lived
out their their lives within that that
sort of framework so you know quite
important
this is another very important one
number eight a friend never asks another
friend to do something wrong this is a
constant tension within friendships and
within the vast literature on friendship
what do you do when your friend comes to
you and says I killed somebody let's
hide the body right or or anything else
doesn't have to be quite so dramatic as
that what do you do and a friend suggest
to you that you should turn a cold
shoulder to somebody who you know
doesn't deserve that right
Cicero thinks that a genuine friendship
is not going to demand that of people
you may be asked to do difficult things
things that you you don't want to do but
they shouldn't be wrong things that you
know that you shouldn't be asked to do
things that are difficult for you
because they're actually wrong and they
they violate your conscience another key
idea of friendships can change over time
we make a lot of friendships at certain
life stages and then we need to you know
see whether they remain friendships or
whether they cool off and break down
even you know sort of just get forgotten
they require some some maintenance and
that also requires that the people grow
into new ways of looking at things
finally number 10 without friends life
is not worth living that's you know a
rather dramatic way of putting it but
it's it's saying that friendship is
actually at the core of what is good in
in life what else do we do we need to
talk about one of the other topics that
is addressed is because it is it
possible to actually define friendship
and and Cicero provides you know a
rough-and-ready definition and saying
that friendship is nothing other than
agreement with goodwill been a volunteer
and affection cantate between people
about all things Devine
and human right so that that provides us
with a sort of structure and criterion
for saying what genuine friendship is
there's also some great discussions in
there about what the basis of friendship
is is base it is friendship based
ultimately on opposites attracting as we
say or as was common in ancient times
you know you you have a friend who you
you you know want to be with and desire
because they supply something that you
lack and you supply something that they
lack or is friendship based on something
else this role actually does think that
the best kind of friendship is based on
a recognition of the moral character of
the other person so you know there could
be a bit of admiration there where
you're like wow that person is really
courageous or really generous I wish I
could be like that but that's not quite
the same thing as need or desire in that
sense where you're like well I want to
be friends with that person because they
have the best parties and I really like
partying man and I don't have the
resources to do that that's a different
kind of thing
so making that distinction is is quite
important a lot of discussion in there
about how friendships break down and and
why and you know what what sort of
problems to look out for and there's a
beautiful passage about you know halfway
through the work where he talks about
virtues and here it is yeah I'm gonna
actually read this to you the men who
claim that virtue is something hard and
rigid like iron are not worth listening
to truly in many aspects of life but
especially in friendship virtue can bend
and yield so that it shapes itself to
the needs of a friend
both in both good times and bad so you
know that that's kind of an interesting
notion to to play around with that
friendship and perhaps other
relationships as well help us to be more
flexible in how we're applying virtue or
moral goodness or rightness and then
finally I'll mention one
they're really kind of cool keypoint and
passage there's this discussion about
the three boundary stones right
he says consider with me the limits and
boundary stones of friendship I'm aware
of three opinions on the subject none of
which I agree with first that we should
care about our friends in the same way
we care about ourselves
second that our goodwill towards our
friends should be exactly equal to their
goodwill towards us third that whatever
value a man puts on himself his friends
should do the same and you know the
first one is is you know fairly
widespread as a belief and and so are
the others and it gets brought up a lot
and Cicero gives you some some you know
reasons why he doesn't buy into any of
these three the other thing that I'll
mention as an important key point as
well that didn't get brought up in that
that summary is something that also
comes up in earlier discussions of
friendship for example I mentioned an
Aristotle friendship has an equalizing
function so that it takes the person
who's better off in certain respects and
allows them to be on the same level as
the person who isn't as well off and
that's that's kind of a interesting
feature of it
Aristotle actually thought this is quite
important and I think Cicero sees that
as is very important as well we don't we
don't have to be exactly the same or a
superlative virtue or anything like that
in order to be friends with each other
and friend friendship provides us with a
framework in which we can become better
people so those are some of the key
ideas of the work hopefully those were
you know tantalizing enough to you that
you'd want to go and read this text
this section on what I found good in the
work is admittedly a little bit short
but you shouldn't infer from it that
there isn't that much good that I found
in the work it's rather that this is
already a great work and this addition
of it is good because it's it's working
off of that it's sort of like having a
symphony performance and you pick the
best music and now you've also got you
know a great Orchestra and a great
conductor and we said oh wow what a
wonderful performance but it's really
Prokofiev who's doing the heavy lifting
right or Rachmaninoff or whoever and its
really sister who's doing the heavy
lifting in this the book looks nice it's
quite attractive in layout and all of
that but of course it wouldn't it
wouldn't be good if it wasn't Cicero
himself and his own you know
genius and diligence that that produced
this so Cicero is always worth reading I
I think that Cicero is a highly
underrated Hellenistic philosopher who
anybody who wants to know anything about
ancient philosophy really does need to
read and and this this one I think is
thought-provoking enough that even if
you're not that interested in ancient
philosophy or philosophy as such you
probably do want to read this because it
gives you a lot of if not necessarily
great advice that you're gonna take
immediately to heart it at least raises
some very important issues about
friendship and relationship that I think
you would want to consider if you want
to be living an intentional life if you
want to be developing if you want to you
know think about the structure and
direction of your relationships so you
know it's it's easy to do good with
Cicero he's sort of like selling a
product that almost sells itself
you know I will mention the translation
is is good I think this is quite
readable and
you know there's some great notes in the
back to help out with with any of that
if you want to read the Latin like I
said you've got it they're on on both
sides which could be a plus for some
readers it's got that nice introduction
as well so you know those are all good
points about it and I think it's you
know they've managed to pick an
attractive looking line for this that's
really all I have to say by way of
what's good about the work but like I
mentioned that's that's in part because
I've already given you a lot of the main
ideas in here and you can you can
probably realize if you're watching this
far in that this this is a book that you
do want to read whether in this edition
or in some other edition and translation
it wouldn't be a Sadler's honest review
if I didn't have this section on what I
found
problematic about the work but this is
actually gonna be rather short because
there there really isn't much that I
find problematic about the book as such
you know I think it's a great work by
Cicero to begin with it's one that I I
enjoy reading myself and recommending
and teaching so obviously that's that's
good so we can talk about the the
addition I don't have anything bad to
say about the translation as I mentioned
I think it's quite readable and I don't
you know there's nothing when I was
going over it or as like I mean I
wouldn't have translated it that way
that doesn't look right it's it's good
so there's nothing on the half front I
will say this and I've mentioned this
with the other books in this series as
well that you know we already do we have
the Loeb Edition where we have facing
Latin in English and and there's you
know plenty of places where you can get
Cicero and Latin online so I'm not quite
sure what the you know what the desire
is to produce a facing pages text it
would be half the length if it were not
facing pages and you know for a book
this size 1695 is a little bit on the
pricey side I've been told by a long
that he found out that in the European
markets people actually do like having
the Latin or Greek on one side in the
English on the other so I have to you
know there's no reason why I would
question his word on that so obviously
for those who do want that sort of thing
it's kind of a plus I think that it
would make for a smaller volume that
would fit more easily into a pocket if
it didn't have the the Latin but I
suppose it's nice to have it every once
in a while so I really don't have much
to say that I think is problematic about
this work
all right final thoughts I recommend
buying this if you don't already have a
copy of Cicero's on friendship this is a
decent one to have particularly if you
do want to be able to study the the
Latin but you're not you know so
invested that you need you know the
whole critical apparatus that a lobe
provides you with it is a great work
even if you're not going to read the
Latin and it's kind of superfluous to
have it on the other side I think that
it's it's a good translation and it's
quite an attractive cover so you know
it's it's well worth having and I will
say this that regardless of whether you
get this Edition and translation or some
other one if you do want to understand
your relationships and you want to get
some expert advice that largely has
stood the test of time for two millennia
I think you do want to read Cicero's day
on maquette SIA or on friendship or in
this case how to be a friend it's it's
really a great work and you shouldn't
deprive yourself of the opportunity to
think alongside one of the brilliant
minds of antiquity who lived a lot
suffered a lot thought a lot argued a
lot and brings a lot to the table
you